you have a long connection to mr. Adam  Sandler a mutual friend of ours because  you guys both grew up in the same town  in southern it's New Hampshire yes  Massachusetts border near the message  I really didn't know Adam until we were  more grown-ups living in New York but my  sister Laura went to school was his age  and his mom was my nursery our parents  are friends and his mom was my nursery  school teacher so the other day he I  went on before him at Largo and then he  went on stage and told this story about  me that I have never heard before about  you when you were in when I was little  yeah cuz his mom tells a story where she  says um a little girl in nursery school  said a swear  and then she was you know scolding  aren't saying you know we don't talk  like that here and I must have overheard  it and I leaned in and I go those are at  home words be always helpful to her so  that's just for home with the parents  you